[Music]
please welcome back to the show the very
funny Rory Scovel hey all right
standing ovations nice thank you hope
the cameras were able to get that
they'll be nice a lot of people home
probably giving a standing ovation -
that's tough to do that's ballsy
you're just given a standing ovation
your wife's in the other room what are
you doing in there I'm clapping for the
guy on TV Diane who's Diane in that
situation you know what I mean
I know what you're all thinking hey is
this that mind-reading comic that's how
to MacFarlane on the ones and twos let
them hear it Adam flew in from
Greenville South Carolina we both grew
up there and I'll tell you what the pot
laws here huh a little bit different in
California you can just kind of smoke
here no one really knows what the laws
are everyone's like I think you can do
it but you know maybe go behind that car
just to be safe play it safe South
Carolina that's not the deal you think a
cop's gonna pull a gun on you what is
that like it's just a stick it's a magic
stick makes me want to paint no is that
bad is art bad problem with legalizing
pot in this country is that there's a
lot of dumb people in this country we're
sort of becoming a dumb country and I
don't say that to offend anybody
but if that does offend you it's
probably because you're too dumb to know
that I'm right legalizing pot is very
difficult you know a lot of people are
against it they think oh it's an
immature drug for high school kids yeah
it is the cool ones remember them kids
who are socially crushing it a little
too soon in life another standing
ovation nice thank you I'm a big fan of
pot I think the reality is pot isn't for
kids it's it's for adults the older you
get the more you realize life is just
chores that's all it is in fact the day
you officially become an adult is the
day that you accept oh my god this is
only chores it doesn't matter how well
you do them how fast you do them they're
coming back tomorrow
they're coming back the next day they're
coming back next week and some people
like oh my god I thought there was more
to life than this there is there's
medicine that you can take that makes
you think that every chore you have to
do is a goddamn video game that you get
to live inside of
[Applause]
grocery shopping high up shut up
nobody likes grocery shopping you're
going to buy groceries that you want to
eat later and you still don't want to go
do it get high go grocery shopping will
quickly become the most expensive
scavenger hunt you have ever been on
everyone who's not clapping you're not
listening you have a list you have a
list that you wrote down at home now
you're at the grocery store hi oh my god
where do we start
salt I have no idea where that is this
could be ours
great great if you're anything like me
you forget that the signs above the
aisles tell you what's in the aisles and
I think a lot of us do that
sober high doesn't matter you forget
those signs are there and you do that
thing we all do you don't want to fully
commit to an aisle so you always take
like two steps in
just peer down the aisle analyze the
food is the food I'm looking for would
it live next to this food you look like
a detective that just barged into a room
to look around quickly what's that down
there jams and jellies
I don't see rice living next to jams and
jellies not after what happened not
after what happened
Adam tickle those keys for him for a
second little here
[Music]
god that feels good you guys ever have
to use the bathroom at the grocery store
answer me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry it's theit's the alcohol they're
not in the corners like they're supposed
to be you have a public restroom put
them in the corners we'll find them
grocery stores are like now we're gonna
put ours beyond these double doors that
you don't even know if you're allowed to
go beyond or not and the doors don't
even say employees only so the mystery
did just de I don't know I can I go back
there you gotta go to go up to some
sixteen-year-old kid who's restocking
the soup and ask for permission to use
the bathroom as an adult hey man can I
go back there beyond those doors they
always act like they don't even know if
they have bathrooms oh you know what let
me get that let me get mad he'll know
dude I have to take him if I have to
piss I go outside like an adult and if I
had enough time to make it home I
wouldn't be talking to you I would abort
this mission I'd be in my car singing to
myself I have three minutes till this
happens my brain just let me in on that
information
my brain was like you got three minutes
till this happens bro you're not
answering a lot of emails from your
colon and that's your fault you might
want to start to think of a solution
you've seen those people at the grocery
store though who realized that they have
to take a crap but they have enough time
to make it home you've never seen them
but you have turned down an island just
seen a grocery cart filled with food and
no one's around
[Music]
hello abduction here you guys that's out
of McFarland I'm a racecar well thank
you very much thank you
let's go
[Applause]